people like to have something to believe
in
what everyone wants magic stories have
to come from someone
we were expecting you an hour ago sorry
Frank
is this miss Lam your new Guardian I
don't want him we've all got to do a bit
I was the first kid school go on then
where is it this is Frank
he's an evacuee from London miss Lam
I know you're busy writing your stories
academic theses today look very
interesting I wrote them do you believe
in heaven
yes well you shouldn't what happened to
all the people who died before the
Christians they did their souls go son
whereas some and it's myth stories have
to come from somewhere
[Applause]
boy it's my dogs 21 squadron well then
what are you waiting for
why didn't you have a husband why don't
you have a wife there was some one
bunnies here we are
so I say make the most of it
[Music]
well she the one you love would you
think it was strange
no it's Frankie
what is it his father we just had the
Telegraph
life is not kind anguish is inevitable
[Music]
what matters it's how you deal with it
all working to bear it on his own it's
not on his own
nobody knows how to be a parent by you -
gosh you make quite a pair
[Music]
you